and one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and I'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking we don't have enough
time for me to list all of our failed
experiments but the big winners pay for
thousands of field experiments I learned
one thing no matter how strong an
elephant is if you're an int if you hide
yourself well an elephant cannot kill
you wanna be happy
build a life not just the business
hates Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn some of the best
lessons from successful billionaires
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one don't be afraid to fail with
Jeff Bezos by the way getting it wrong
isn't that bad that's the other thing
when when we make mistakes and we've
made Dizzy's like the fire phone and
many other things that just didn't work
out I can I could look we don't have
enough time for me to list all of our
failed experiments but the big winners
pay for thousands of failed experiments
so you try something like prime and it
was very expensive at the beginning it
cost us a lot of money because what
happens when you offer a free
all-you-can-eat buffet who shows up to
the buffet first the heavy eaters
it's scary it's like oh my god did I
really say as many prawns as you can eat
and and so that is what happened but but
surely we could see the trend lines we
could see that you know the different
all kinds of customers were coming and
they appreciated that service lesson
number two
don't rely on wishful thinking Elon Musk
I think it mean if you want to make
progress and things I think that but the
the best analytical framework for us and
in the future is physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like not just not
the equations I mean equations certainly
they're helpful but the way of thinking
in physics is the that's the best
framework for understanding things that
are counterintuitive and and you know
always taking the position that you are
some degree wrong and your goal is to be
less wrong over time the one of the
biggest mistakes people generally make
and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore the things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having problems with but if you just
take that approach of your oyster some
degree wrong and your goal is to be less
wrong and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends I
take a friend's if somebody loves you
they want the best for you they don't
want to tell you the bad things so you
have to ask them okay you know it said
really I really do want to know
and then they'll tell you lesson number
three have a competitive advantage with
Warren Buffett what are the key
indicators you look for within companies
before making an investment well I look
for something that does give them a
motor Rob we have a company called See's
candy out on the west coast See's
Candies watch chocolates if you give a
box of see Charlotte's to your
girlfriend of the first day and she
kisses you we own you you know we need
we can raise the price tomorrow I you'll
buy the safe box you're not gonna fall
out with success so the key there is the
response you do not want to go home on
Valentine's Day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart preferably they're the
same person
you don't say here honey I took two
whole bed it doesn't work
prices to a degree is immaterial if
you've got a economic castle the people
are gonna come in want to take that
castle away from you and you better have
a strong vote you better have a night
mint Castle that knows what he's doing
also if you want to have more self love
and confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join on the
description below if everything has to
work in two to three years then that
limits what you can do become so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed there are times when if
something is important enough you
believe in it enough but you do you do
it in spite of fear lesson number four
change your thinking with Jack Ma the
African desert ever agree is that the
eCos is not controlled by lions and
elephants the ecosystem is controlled by
the insects in the mud last century the
company the big the better
so everybody want to be a big company
the powerful company this century from
now a good company is more important a
powerful company where you compete to is
become I think in past 20 years within
completing with Erica
putting lots of companies in China but I
learned one thing no matter how strong
an elephant is if you're an INT if you
hide yourself well an elephant cannot
kill you you can kill the elephant if
you're in a better way
it's about your thinking lesson number
five set boundaries with Oprah Winfrey
when I first started making money I was
one of those people who thought I got it
every time somebody asked me I got a
yeah so you go crazy you have to look
within yourself what do you want to do
that that that means family members
because you get a lot of cousins when
you get the ban Jones show all of a
sudden you get killed so you decide for
yourself and so I have you know I've
given away so much yes that people don't
know because most of the time you don't
hear about it more than you ever did
I've held so people complain about what
I did or didn't do yeah I don't know me
don't know know me I do yeah I do and
and I don't have any let me get let me
get one more all of that very much in
check unless the number six the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
study success with Mark Zuckerberg
there's this culture in Silicon Valley
that kind of makes startups in glamorous
and I never really believed that right I
never had a goal of starting a startup
and my goal when I realized that I had a
company was to get it to be a good
company as quickly as possible where I
didn't kind of get out of what you'd
call they're like risky startup phase
where you are just like constantly about
to die and where you could get to a
point where you can actually do some
interesting things and make make a lot
of more interesting bets and um so I
don't know I I never read a lot of the
literature on this and I mean maybe if I
had then I wouldn't made so many
mistakes but so I don't know if like if
learning for me is the right way to go
on this but I mean but it did your model
must have come from somewhere though
even if it was even if you it was
unintentional
right like were you influenced by Peter
Thiel where Sean well yes all these
people once
met them I actually I hadn't really
heard of Peter teal before I'm talking
yeah right yeah but he was massively
influential on my thinking right I mean
I like a lot of the the early lessons
that I took on how to think about
strategy came from Peter and Sean and I
did pay a lot of attention when I was
growing up to Microsoft I thought I mean
I grew up you know using you know
Windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and I
just thought that those were like the
most unbelievable things and since they
are yeah they really were awesome right
well I don't know if you meant that
positive positively but I did and and I
thought you know building this ecosystem
was really neat and that kind of
inspired me right in the way that they
built a platform I kind of thought okay
well maybe one day you know that the
tools that I'm building can be part of a
broader ecosystem as well now I have a
special bonus clip from billionaire John
Paul DeJoria on how to be an eagle that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action here
we go question a boy who are three
successful people who you can study this
week number two where do you need to set
more boundaries in your life and number
three what's the potential failure that
you need to stop fearing and if you made
it this far in the video I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag believe
down the comments when God created this
planet he created up several species
enough you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say God for now
setup save God the forest God the forest
let's just say God right now God creates
the planet Earth and first of all he
creates which a lot of people and
different organizations want a perfect
social economic world where everything
is free don't worry about a thing you're
taking care of there's no extra
imagination necessary because all gonna
be given to you so he creates the oyster
eases oyster I'm giving you a free house
to live in I'm calling it a shell I'm
gonna put at the bottom of the ocean to
protect you from your enemies you have
food clothing all the foods you want
protection everything you want the
perfectly taken care of while you're in
your measly little life as an oyster but
you're not gonna go anywhere
your stay there at the Bob the ocean but
you're totally got your free food free
clothing for everyone then God created
something called the Eagle Eagle whole
different species eagle you want a house
you go out and build it date the top of
a mountain take the top of a tree go out
and build your own house you want some
food to eat no problem go out there and
find it eagle and the eagle flies
through miles in the winter time of rain
sleet snow and whim just to feed its
young did you know the Eagle fails 95%
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey they're wild they should
offered a different direction and it
misses 5% of the time it succeeds and
what does succeed to do it succeeded to
being the strongest bird in the sky the
only one that we know of anywhere in the
world that could fly into the thermals
of a hurricane and ride them to have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
any where it wants anywhere it wants
yeah Gamble's it does is on its own but
it goes wherever it wants now that Eagle
and not the oyster is the emblem of
America and also on the flag of many
many countries you wouldn't be in this
room right now if you weren't Eagles
don't only imagine start doing it thank
you peace love and happiness all of you
thank you very much
[Music]
if you want more lessons from successful
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and I'm gonna tell you something
that a lot of people 99 percent of
people disagree with me on it wasn't as
though in creating these companies that
we thought that we would be successful